or they teach a seminar you guys just
had a lot of people
you didn't say that my house would
double in its value in two years why say
whatever you gotta say to close the deal
don't you hey would you like to take a
tour of my house my personal gym this is
where the pools gonna go right here I'm
gonna do a little swim up bar right
there it's gonna be sexy as Elvis these
are your kids
Jason Penn that's me you know I'm just
gonna say it aloud is dead
I have a daughter shut up actually I'm
sorry I didn't mean that I have kids and
that was mean here's the plan we're
gonna take Gary's body bodies are like
super heavy right and we're gonna chop
it up like civilized people
[Music]
Jesse I told you I wasn't gonna kill you
nine-one-one what's your emergency
there's a man inside there and he's
killed people it's got a lot of guns
yeah boy
so do i I'm looking for my ex-wife my
daughter I'll help you find him
okay I got I gotta get out of here
I need everyone to be nice to each other
until it gets dark relax
put some TV on god dammit
okay we're not gonna watch TV no one's
watching TV okay
you